[Música]
bienvenidos a medio ambiente desde casa
en france24 esta semana hacemos un
repaso por algunas de las noticias
ambientales de los últimos días y
comenzamos en el espacio porque la
agencia espacial europea junto con nasa
y la oficina de administración oceánica
y atmosférica de estados unidos lanzarán
en noviembre un satélite que vigilará la
tierra y cuanto están cambiando los
niveles del mar
el satélite llamado sentinel 6 obtendrá
las mediciones más precisas que existen
hasta el momento sobre el aumento del
nivel del agua algo que ayudará a los
científicos a estudiar como el cambio
climático y el calentamiento global
están afectando a nuestros océanos si
les lys
el nivel del mar es un síntoma directo
del calentamiento global así que es muy
importante medirlo de manera precisa el
aumento del nivel del mar está
relacionado al derretimiento del hielo
de los polos y también está relacionado
a la acumulación de calor en los océanos
así que esos dos elementos unidos hacen
que el sentinel 6 sea muy relevante para
la sociedad shakesperiano legrand for
four que esto es haití el aumento del
nivel del mar cuyo motor primordial está
demostrado es la actividad humana tiene
graves efectos tanto para los
ecosistemas como para las poblaciones
costeras causa erosión de las costas y
con ello inundaciones además del posible
desplazamiento de millones de personas
el sentinel 6 estará cinco años y medio
tomando mediciones y será relevado en
2025 por otro satélite idéntico que
seguirá tomando información desde el
espacio durante otros cinco años en
otras noticias una auditoría alertó a la
unión europea de que seguramente no
cumpla con sus objetivos de reciclaje de
envoltorios plásticos que en 2018
formaban el 40 por ciento de los más de
29 millones de toneladas de elementos de
este material que desecharon los
habitantes del bloque comunitario ese
año la unión europea se había
comprometido a reciclar el 50 por ciento
de estos envoltorios plásticos para el
2025 sin embargo en la actualidad la
mayoría se incinera y se calcula que
sólo el 32 por ciento es reciclado
además este problema podría haberse
agravado ahora por la cantidad de
exorbitante de desechos plásticos de un
solo uso como guantes o mascarillas que
la pandemia de kobe 19 han generado uno
de los mayores obstáculos para el
reciclaje es la falta de instalaciones
en la región ya que actualmente al menos
una quinta parte de los envoltorios
plásticos son enviados a otros países
para ser reciclados sin embargo desde
que china anunció que a partir de 2018
ya no recibiría productos de europa o de
otros países occidentales la unión
europea ha visto dificultada su
operación y los plásticos de menor
calidad y cuyo reciclaje no es tan
rentable
en los centros de acopio la comisión
europea para intentar minimizar el
impacto de los plásticos propondrá
nuevas leyes en 2021 para que todos los
envoltorios sean reciclables o
reutilizables antes del año 2030
seguimos en la unión europea y es que
francia dio un paso más hacia su plan de
prohibición total del glifosato que el
presidente manuel macro no había
prometido para el año que viene el
glifosato es un polémico químico que se
utiliza para matar hierbas y que ha
estado involucrado en demandas por
supuestamente tener efectos nocivos en
la salud de las personas y que según la
organización mundial de la salud puede
llegar a producir cáncer el herbicida
sólo podrá ser utilizado en el país
siempre y cuando no exista otra
alternativa no química al producto y que
está disponible a corto plazo el
glifosato sólo se podrá usar cuando el
terreno o el tipo de cultivo no permitan
que se quiten las hierbas de manera
mecánica el uso del herbicida podrá
continuar en otras industrias no
agrícolas como por ejemplo en el
mantenimiento de ferrocarriles
autopistas o aero
hasta que se encuentre una alternativa
no química que no altere la seguridad de
los usuarios de estos servicios que
representan menos del 15 por ciento del
uso total del ifo sato en francia- y
finalizamos con una iniciativa que
podría ser revolucionaria en la lucha
contra el tráfico de animales en
concreto de las tortugas o más bien de
sus huevos la organización
conservacionista paso pacífico que se
dedica a la protección de especies y
ecosistemas del pacífico centroamericano
desarrollo con tecnología de impresión
3d unos huevos de tortuga en los que
colocan sensores gps y que utilizan como
señuelo para rastrear posibles
traficantes ilegales los huevos falsos
que son impresos de la manera más
realista posible con la textura y forma
de un huevo real son colocados en los
nidos donde desovan las tortugas por
ejemplo las tortugas verdes suelen poner
unos 120 huevos lo que hacemos es
colocar un huevo señuelo en el centro
para que esté lo más escondido posible y
normalmente se llevan toda la puesta de
huevos
en esta prueba que hicieron colocaron
huevos falsos en más de 100 miedos de
tortuga en costa rica una cuarta parte
de los señuelos fue removida de los
nidos de forma ilegal de este
experimento salió que los huevos
impresos no interferían con la
incubación de los embriones y que los
señuelos funcionaban bien en el rastreo
del tráfico ilegal y aunque la mayoría
de los huevos no sale del mercado local
algunos viajaron largas distancias no lo
pusimos el sábado en la noche y dejó la
playa el lunes en la mañana viajo 137
kilómetros tierra adentro y paro así que
en mi aplicación móvil de google maps y
sesum y fui capaz de identificar el
supermercado exacto a donde llegó pero
no estaba adentro estaba a la vuelta de
la esquina en un callejón porque
estarías ahí con huevos de tortugas si
no es para hacer algo sospechoso
somos especies a raíz del experimento no
se llevaron a cabo arrestos pero la
organización quería demostrar que la
tecnología si funciona y que podría ser
una herramienta muy útil para
identificar a los traficantes
esperan que se pueda utilizar en la
lucha del tráfico ilegal de otras
especies animales y vegetales es todo
por esta semana recuerden que pueden
volver a ver todas las emisiones de
medio ambiente en nuestro sitio web
france24 puntocom
hasta la próxima